welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
Daniel magaziner an assistant professor
of history at Yale University professor
magaziner is an intellectual historian
specializing in 20th century south
africa in 2010 he published his first
book the law and the prophets black
consciousness in South Africa a history
of political thought in 1970s South
Africa today we talk with Professor
Magaziner about his new research project
tentatively titled on a contested canvas
artists and the art of life in 20th
century South Africa welcome professor
magaziner thank you for having me let's
begin with an overview of your book tell
us about it why should first say that
this book is as yet unwritten so is a
potential book and potentially what I
what I hope that it will be is an
intellectual history of black visual
artists in South Africa from the 1920s
until the 1980s and looking primarily at
painters and sculptors and especially at
people who consider themselves modern
artists which was a category that didn't
really exist in South Africa for
especially for Africans there was a
small white modern art scene but not a
very large African art modern art scene
ok and so what I'm looking at are the
intellectual experiences of those
artists their social experiences their
training their education and so on
during a period that stretches from the
advent of segregation in South Africa in
the early part of the 20th century until
the 1980s when the apartheid system that
was a successor to that the system of
white minority rule in South Africa was
beginning to be taken apart okay and how
did the book come to be written or how
did you get the idea to write the book
the book in many ways grows out of my
first projects my first project was
about activists and student activists
especially in church activists in the
1970s who developed an ocean from the
late 1960s into the early
1970s that the only appropriate response
to apartheid was to be political across
every facet of your being you needed to
think about politics always you needed
to be politically engaged always and one
of the results of that in the 1970s was
the emergence of a very politically
engaged art form you saw people
beginning to paint explicitly political
themes you saw people be able to write
poetry that wasn't about love or
anything like that but instead was about
oppression about the experience of
living in South Africa's townships about
dispossession and land alienation you
saw music that was explicitly political
in its form and content and one of the
things I realized was that was all very
fine and good but what I had traced was
a historical phenomenon by which
activists became convinced that this was
the only appropriate form of art that
was out there and when I looked at the
literature on 20th century South African
art what I saw was that scholars had
tended to always read it as if it was by
nature and by definition political they
had in a sense allowed the reality of
art as it was as it came to exist in the
1970s and 1980s they allowed that
reality to influence how they explored
the potential for art and during
previous decades this was not a
coincidence because much of the
scholarship in South African art was
written in the 1980s at a time when the
art was avowedly political so when
scholars went to look at arts they
always focused on the political aspects
of then art and so what I began to be
interested in was if it had been created
this notion of a political art had been
created during the 1960's and 1970's
what other forms of art existed what
other forms of engagement existed and so
I began Thai set out to research that
and and and ultimately that is what I've
turned into this book prize okay is
dance a part of it as well vision you
know um dance is not a part of it I wish
that it were and part I I'm not very
well versed in the literature on Dan I
see and there's that which does exist
tens along the same paradigms so I would
imagine that there would be a potential
for a project but it's not
that's been standing here so far let's
talk about how you did the research for
the book what was your methodology um
well the thing about South Africa that
makes it somewhat unique among African
countries is that because of the
infrastructure that went along with
white white supremacy South Africa was
in many senses a fully developed country
with a large underclass of people who
had no access to them I'm in terms of
art what that meant was that South
Africa had museums and art galleries it
had art critics it had all of these
things stretching back to the 1920s in
the 1930s and because of that as a
result of that along the way there were
certain number of artists who emerged
who get picked up by the media and who
become relatively well-known in their
time and after the fact and at first
this is very few then it becomes more
and more and so what I was trying to do
initially my initial approach was to try
to figure out what sort of documentary
record was left by these artists and
that's kind of an important innovation
there because much of the work that's
done on artists tends to be focused on
their works I'm very interested in their
works their works are quite striking in
many in many cases but what I'm most
interested in is are their experiences
up to that moment when they began to
paint or began to sculpt how was that
they were reflecting what had happened
previously in the work that emerges so I
needed to find some other sources um
paintings tend to you make an initial
stroke then you paint him one on top of
it and so paintings present a completed
picture and I wanted to kind of
disaggregate it take it apart so I went
into museums i went into our galleries i
went to the collections of private
collectors and i tried to find any
documentary evidence that they have and
it was it was not the easiest task
because there's not very much of it
there was very little coverage in white
newspapers of black artists most
newspapers tended to focus on white
artists they were for a white audience
and it was only in the 1960s really the
black newspapers and black media began
to pick up and cover black artists so
I've spent a lot of time just trying to
piece together a documentary record
were you looking for what their
day-to-day lives were alike up to the
point they started to produce art
day-to-day lives to an extent and the
thing about it is that we do have a
pretty extensive historiography on
social experience in 20 centuries Africa
so i can make general claims about their
day-to-day existence what we don't have
as good a record on is how people
responded to it how people thought about
it now they reflected on it so what I
was looking at was especially
indications of their critical approach
to their lives how they understood what
was happening so I was trying to find
comments in newspapers say that didn't
make much sense given what I know about
social experience 20 century South
Africa and I've got a number of things
that were surprising in that way and
that allowed me to kind of begin to make
claims about the individual social the
individual intellectual experience of
these people which was what I was trying
to get at initially we're able to speak
to any living people okay i did i did my
as a twentieth century historian i'm
fortunate because i do i am you able to
do interviews many of the people i'm
most interested in the very long lives
but died before i became interest in the
subject unfortunately the period that i
began to focus on most intently was the
interwar period the 1920s to the 1940s
and there was about five major
self-conscious black modern artists
during that time period many of them
live very long lives but they died in
the 1990s which meant that I didn't ever
have a chance to interview them I've
done interviews with people who came in
later generations artists especially in
the 1960s and 1970s and I'm currently
working with researchers at the
University of kwazulu-natal in South
Africa to basically try and find more
people to interview and we were placing
ads in newspapers and trying to expand
our vision of who we could talk them for
the project okay so how does your work
differ at this point from the other
books and literature that are out there
now um it differs in two ways I think
depending on which literature we decided
that we wanted
dress in terms of 20th century South
African historiography the literature
written by historians about this time
Pierre that I'm covering there's
absolutely or I should not say
absolutely loves little bit overstated
there is very little coverage of
anything other than politics and when I
say politics I mean politics kind of
writ large I don't mean just political
party maneuvering the rise of resistance
movements but I mean those things that
we associate is being inherently
political the economy land alienation
forced removals of people violence these
sorts of things that are the common
stories we get 20th century South Africa
there's very little about or a good way
i can explain is this artist's traveled
for training and in search of source
material and they traveled on trains
they traveled on buses we don't have any
accounts of black experience in 20th
century South Africa that talk about
travel because you're trying to better
yourself what we have instead are more
accounts of people traveling because
they're forced to because the government
has told them they have to leave their
homes because the government is because
of the industries that exist that force
them into migrant labor entire so in
terms of 20th century historiography
there's very little on these sorts of
people in terms of art history which is
the other discipline I'm interested in I
already mentioned how I'm less
interested in the works themselves
although that is part of the project
part of the problem with art history as
I see it is they tend to think that
artists that genius is this thing that
travels from individual artists to
individual artists to individual artists
and though there is a lot of material
written on save these early black modern
artists i mentioned a minute ago what
happens is art history tends to elevate
those single moments where one artist
men and other artists and to say that's
what matters and there are subsequent
development for me I think I have a
different approach I'm trying to place
these artists within a wider more
broader intellectual society where
there's lots of people who don't happen
to become artists but who are interested
in ideas about creativity who have ideas
about what is the appropriate production
of a creative individual
and their time period in South Africa
and so what I try to do is widen that
realm in which the Arts exists and so I
do that by supplementing traditional art
history resources with other forms of
evidence such as what well the biggest a
little research adequate that might help
illustrate what I'm trying to say here
over the course of the 20th century by
the 1980s I would say there were no more
than 30 to 40 recognizable names in
black art and that gave me very limited
source space as I discovered and the as
I was going through my research I
discovered that I was limited in terms
of what I can say and so what I tried to
do was say okay how can we widen the
category of artists what we tend to see
is those people who actually make sales
those people get covered in the
newspaper those become artists but what
I was thinking was that there are other
people in society who think of
themselves as interested in arts and so
what I tried to do was figure out how to
how to do that and I got very fortunate
at one point I was reading a very short
monograph written by one relatively
well-known artists tamenund enraha wat
day and in it there was evident that
suggested that raha wat dey had
correspond with someone I never heard of
a woman named Lorna Pearson and that
there existed somewhere at an archive in
durban there existed a large
correspondence file of correspondence
tween this man in this woman and I never
heard of her I bet I figured I needed
more of evidence so I traveled to Durban
and I went there what I discovered in
fact was that raha wat dey was
corresponding with his former teacher
and that he had been trained by this
woman not to be an artist but to be an
art teacher in schools reserved for
Africans under what was called Bantu
education who's they the white
minorities attempt to control African
education beginning the 1950s and what I
discovered was that that correspondent
file was one of actually hundreds of
correspondence files that existed
between this woman who was the head art
teacher and principal of the school and
her students many of whom never produced
any art works but all of whom thought of
themselves as artists
and they pursued that quest to be
artists under the Bantu education system
by trying to become art educators
because it was very hard to make it as
an artist but if you get someone to pay
you then you could try and make your way
and have some time to do your own you
must have been thrilled to have
discovered that it was a big moment yeah
it was a big moment it was a very short
trip I was with my wife and my at that
point two year old daughter in German
and we had only plans a few days and
those days became frenetic as of illicit
photocopy and picture taken and then
going back and asking permission to use
all of those pictures and images that
I'd collected because I wasn't sure if I
could get back actually I was able to go
back and have been working through that
archive and that's become a major part
of my project let me ask you this of
that small group of artists that were
producing art do they communicate with
each other at all was it a very much a
community or not so much they attempt to
what I discover is that because they are
so isolated they it becomes even more
vital that they can establish
connections with other artists so many
of them come out of of school
experiences and art school night school
experiences in particular beginning in
the late 1940s there's this great
concern among the johannesburg city
government johannesburg being the
largest city in south africa that
there's this big population of africans
who don't have anything to do at night
and they're very worried because they
think if they're not don't really do a
night they could get in all sorts of
trouble right so one of their solutions
is to say we need to come up with
cultural activities at various
city-owned buildings where people can go
when they can study piano and study
singing and so on one of these becomes
art and so begin in the late 1940s the
government begins a series of night
schools for aspirant artists people who
work as clerks or medical assistance or
have some sort of petty bourgeois job in
the city during the day and then at
night they go when they study painting
under white artists for a couple of for
a few hours these people tended to
develop interests along the same lines
their works tended to take on a very
similar form evidence of their training
and so on and so you see these little
school
that emerged and so one of the product
the aspects of the project is tracing
these little communities and how these
communities are disseminated under
apartheid though the government this was
a project that was kind of undertaken
right before the apartheid government
was developed and one of the things that
apartheid does is it further roads
Africans access to city centers so over
the course of the 1950s and 1960s these
night schools eventually get shut down
they get shut down in all art education
gets focused instead on rural areas in
areas that are reserved for African
residents okay so one of the things that
you creasing Lisi is the efforts to
maintain a community of artists become
more fraught because artists are being
trained further and further away from
their homes and then they're found in
themselves more and more isolated so
I've tried to collect correspondence
tried to collect evidence of these
connections that these artists are
trying to maintain okay final question I
know the book is not complete yet but
have you been able to come to any
conclusions I have I'm playing around
with some tentative conclusions um I
have some conclusions in terms of how if
you look at artists you see the history
of 20th century South Africa differently
how the chronology is different how the
question of politics changes at various
moments and those are conclusions I
think will be interested to to
historians and to others the conclusion
i'm most excited about that i'm most i
should also say perhaps worried about is
a reassessment of intellectual life
under apartheid the general consensus
had long been that are in scholarship
that under apartheid no authentic
intellectual life was possible there was
either the intellectual life of
resisting the movement which was a sort
which was of course authentic but was
limited because then when apartheid
ended the question of what would happen
or that political energy was was left
open and then there was the idea that
apartheid because of controlled
education becomes a controlled culture
to some extent that it was limiting any
authentic African intellectual
creativity during this time period what
i've discovered is that that wasn't the
case what i've discovered is that under
the system of Bantu education which was
oppressive which was intellectually
spear
in all sorts of ways there existed
elements of creativity and elements of
freedom that teachers tried to cultivate
and so when looking at art education I
see the ways in which art educators were
convinced that they were inculcating
these values of individual creativity
that were vital to being modern it
modern people in the 20th century not
Africans not South Africans just people
it was part of being human and that they
were reading much wider than apartheid
they're reading John Dewey they were
thinking about all these these really
important ideas but they were doing so
under the aegis of the most perfect
system of racial oppression that had
ever that has ever existed and so that's
caused me to ask new questions about the
potential for understanding apartheid I
mean that is very curious ironic it's
deeply ironic and it's very problematic
because when I've mentioned it to people
people say are you suggesting there is
anything good in Bantu education which
is anathema and I'm not suggesting
there's anything good but I'm suggesting
that people made of the system things
that we haven't yet accounted for and
that we need to account for what people
made of the system because when then we
can actually offer a more fair
assessment I think as apartheid recedes
into the past and is now been 18 years
since the end of apartheid people are
beginning to wonder okay what how else
can we see the 20th century does it have
to be just this this analysis of racism
this analysis of state oppression can we
begin to open new sorts of dialogues and
I think that my project hopefully will
contribute to to that to that overall
project fascinating stuff but look
forward to your book thank you for more
information about professor magaziner
and his work please visit our website at
yale edu slash macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
you